but now I've seen you do a thing and I
like your on a suit but can you do the
deadlift thing space
[Applause]
okay so don't now slam me on my yes
so the takeoffs we're gonna set you down
Jenna thank you thank you let me tell
you so gentle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
five nine four to beat here we go here
we go
[Applause]
Anthony Joshua
look I'm still going okay aw what was
yours eight eight P was three thousand
there was six seven two wasn't what six
seven two six three two so if you don't
beat back so tightly okay okay here we
go here we go this technique adieu the
world champion
there's something so joyful about how
confident and on the top of your cave
you were like this photograph says it
already this is you in Rio
look at those poor Egypt
their souls let their bodies what was
going through your mind then just
thinking I am very good I don't know
what happened I wasn't I can't remember
smiling in there I thought it was gonna
be heavier okay okay you go first you
mind the cameras here we go
so golf Oh
[Applause]
well you might as well
hit the bell
you are getting is Mb you got I got
their media so now she knows right yeah
did you know anything I turn one down it
wasn't strictly offered it up and said
I'm not interested anything about
Formula one she actually did when she
was talking to me there and she saying
we watch you but the best thing is I got
invited back I could get later for lunch
the group that was about there's about
eight of us and we turned up after the
Brazilian Grand Prix came back and
walked in saw the the seating plan and I
was sat right next to her so I was kind
of excited you thought you read yeah
yeah so I sat down and she was to my
right and I started to talk to her and
she's like she's like no you you you
speak that way first and I will speak
this way and I come back to you cards
like me I don't have your questions
don't be the woman from that charity now
Lisa spoke to the guy next to her for
like five five minutes and then she
spent the rest of time talking to me yes
you won it it was really really cool
David do that hair bring you back is
that why they cut you from Norwich the
weird thing I missed your man like
you're not Rachel from friends and yet
whatever you do to your hair it becomes
a thing yeah it does believe it or not
yeah there's certain ones that I've just
done just off the cuff so there's no
shame in some of them before doing it
you had the top knot there you go lovely
burn that's what was a practical it's
not that this one okay what was going on
here that was maybe a bad decision yeah
it was a bad time in as well because I
was actually going to South Africa at
the time with England and I ended up
meeting Nelson Mandela I know you do and
and the pictures the madness one the
most um David Beckham look I think is
this one seemed like you at or big
smiley face there no well I don't know
why I had that want I was asked to shave
it off when I first did it I was I was
sat in the changing room and I had a hat
on at the time because Sir Alex Ferguson
hadn't seen it so obviously that was
interesting when I took my hat off and
we had an hour before the kickoff and he
said go and shave it off
which I said no at first and then I saw
his face change very quickly so I have
when I shaved it off in the in the
toilet Alex folks some would actually be
some strict on that stuff very really
very yeah what it is it was just you
know it was a reputation of the club
wanted all the players to kind of be
professional and he felt that it wasn't
the right look and I shaved it off we
were playing at wembley as well so it
kind of a boy classic rock pose with the
eyebrows that that signature eyebrow
look at that this is the kind of pre
match is this the pre match yeah that's
like the bits the pre match it's the
preamble it's a talking trash that is a
I had a catch phrase that that that went
with is that it doesn't matter
that's it doesn't matter how did it
doesn't matter what cuz it doesn't sound
like a catch phrase how did it work as a
catch phrase well whoever I was in the
ring with and stupids been there are
many occasions right so whoever I was in
the ring with so for example if it were
you and I it'll be like Graham what do
you think you're gonna do tonight when
we get in the ring well
[Applause]
that's how it kind of works if you smell
if you smell what The Rock is cooking
how did that work then in in a sentence
oh well that that works in a sentence a
statement a question it works anywhere
right when you wake up right well before
you go to bed it's just you could just
say it if you smell what The Rock is
quicker yeah but you got to say it
probably with a little bit like you know
shout that one as well
it's hard I generally have a microphone
I'm doing alright here we go
so it all starts with the bass okay okay
got to open your legs a little bit okay
okay you got to kind of do one of these
yeah lean forward a little bit yeah come
back here's where you got to do a little
tongue thing with the rock and then
there's a little pause there's like a
big pregnant pause that you have to do
so the audience kind of leans in a
little bit is
[Applause]
[Music]
you